[Music]
would be emotionally or just push me
[Music]
okay
I'm ready I'm ready to talk about it oh
my good
every day my son because he puts extra
effort and everything he does and I'm
doing some of the things that he does
going surfing going swimming that he
supplied so it was about 14 years ago
this the name of the dog is still my
password for everything so this was this
was very deeply emotional for me it was
late night it was my sister's birthday
actually I think it was her 15th
birthday and all the adults were having
a good time and they left the side gate
open so the dog had run away from the
party there's too much noise it was my
first pet I grew up with his dog I
raised his dog and it ran all the way up
to the side street it's kind of a busy
street I guess and people drive up and
down drunk haulin ass pretty frequently
and we heard a loud screeching sound
like tires I guess so we went up to the
road just to check it out with others
maybe a car accident or something notice
the dog was missing and everyone started
panicking and they didn't want me to go
because I was too little at the time but
I scooted all the way out there it was
like half a mile away and I saw my dog
was still alive on the side of the road
black lab beautiful she was only
shoot like eight years old I guess so
she was getting up there but too young
too young for time and
you know I ran up to her I held on her
and I'd bawl my eyes out of course I was
a little little one but she died right
there with me on the side of the road
we had a little funeral for that night
dug a little hole everyone helped kind
of dig one shovelful at a time but you
know it taught me about loss until then
I had no one in my life died no family
members or anything it was kind of the
closest
thing that I felt to losing something
important in my life
and I still think about it almost every
day to this day
I say I said my grandma I mean she hit
me at pool I feel like you see how is
the fluid me she a big influence on me
she made me she helped me think mentally
she keeps me going super motivate me
not likely I like that about her and I
like in a woman field said that to my
grandma I miss you and I love you I wish
to me I love you I love you so much
you say I wish I could be with you right
now but I know you gone soft
well I seen this old lady fall and I
seen this little killer awake hope it
rocks can try on my eggs let me my
girlfriend left me a very emotional so
my dad during Christmas time always says
that the homeless people are diesel so
he always gives them a lot of money your
kitchen
you know they're angels so last
Christmas we stopped the gas station my
dad keep them my dollar bill hundred
dollar bill and one of them started
crying but like I really needed this at
this moment because my wife is a lot of
pressure she's pregnant and we really
needed us to stay in her house and it
was like just a really nice moment so
now I always tip doing Christmas is
they're angels good I was going
skydiving and I told her my friends from
I've known for a long time like two
months ago we didn't we don't talk that
much but she didn't talk to me for about
a month and the day before I went
skydiving she asked me to be careful in
the message fair as soon as I land and I
decided at that moment I'm I'm gonna
write after her school go skydiving
let's hang out and after that we started
dating so that moved me and then I got a
girlfriend so I was amazing absolutely
just today I was walking down the
boardwalk and I spoke someone I've never
met before
she's from Eugene Oregon and she's here
just for a weekend
so I was just walking on the boardwalk
and this guy asked me to have lunch with
him and his friends and actually ended
up being really cool group of people and
now we're gonna go for a dip
I would I went into the ocean not too
long ago and there was a refreshing
experience I don't really go to the
ocean so so recently like last week
there two weeks ago my close friend
passed away and
I had it I haven't I've had like friends
of our family of friends or friends of
family that passed away but never like
the close friend to me and this dude
just influenced all of us so much it's
so crucial to like me growing up and
everyone else growing up and how we kind
of progressed into our different hobbies
and whatnot and bad last week we had a
big memorial like skate session at his
favorite skate park and just seeing
everyone together all all at once just
really gave me like huge perspective I
mean I go day to day and just think
about like you know am i spending my
hours well am i doing things that I
should be or that are important and I
guess any time losing someone is never
easy for anyone but just I guess that
was my first realization where it's like
nothing really matters
and you just gotta be with your friends
and family and everyone everyone takes
something away from everyone you meet so
hopefully it's something good I've seen
people do stuff for other people like my
she helped a friend whose parent
recently died because she decided to buy
them like new likes clothes for school
and
so that was pretty cool that one's me
today my daughter was born it moves me
is like very touching you know kind of
changed my life I was a little bit
younger so then once I it just like it
helped me all like with my journey in
life you know with my life decisions and
my choices and stuff like that that I
made like even to this day when I met it
when I met a girl from Mexico because
she was different from any other girl I
dated she's Mexican
I was watching the news the other day
and I heard a guy talking about man your
hero your hero and the guy was like no
man that's just what we do and it was
awesome to see you know all those people
in Houston in Texas it's like going
all-out and you know doing what they do
for each other so the time that comes to
mind it was when after my last high
school sport my my dad he said he was
proud of me for all accomplishments
during high school which was very
unexpected because we had a tough love
relationship at all but it was really
moving at the time yeah I volunteer at a
sharp Memorial Hospital and I ask for
people and their families to their
surgery waiting rooms and there was one
young man that it was just so mindful
with his old people that
very peacefully quietly helping him we
were at church and somebody the pastor
actually saw that we were helping out in
a church and doing things like a lot of
different things and he said it in front
of everybody so I was honored and
humbled at the same time and I don't
move
my grandmother who's now deceased
decided to leave me her cookie jar her
kitchen that she got on her first
anniversary and she was married in 1967
years and she left that to me in her
will so I was breaking happy about that
actually in light of recent events I
think that all of the penalty that
company's football players there's a lot
of people that are helping out all the
Texans specifically
that's fantastic to see that we're
actually getting good media coverage on
something that's helpful and it's
bringing the unity amongst a lot of
people all across the country so I'd say
that's the biggest thing is it's seeing
kind of everyone come together because
we I don't think we have seen that in a
while so that's actually really inspired
I'm 60 through 60 years of living [ __ ]
happened so I don't know what you're
looking for is hard [ __ ] well she she
ended up being a having an addiction
that she couldn't let go but we spent
like a year trying to make things work
and they never worked because of this
eviction
so I knows a little heartbroken I'm
getting over it so but that moved me you
asked me and I told you something really
working I was in a dark place one time
and then I heard hear this guy singing I
thought ballpark you know and I heard
before but this time I'll just pass you
by and he's like come here do you like
the music I was like yeah and it's you
know like I became really good friends
that guy and like every time I would go
to the park I look forward to seeing him
and like he recently passed so like that
came to mind you know I missed that guy
he really really he really changed me
musically you know like let me realize
you know we didn't talk about serious
stuff the music you know so we were
there connected Jayco children and one
time one of the be one of the children I
coach came and gave me a hug and that
was very truthful and that was the best
thing ever
nothing moves me emotionally doesn't
never ever no not even bad I mean is yup
no don't let my emotions get in the way
yup just focus on me not too long ago I
was in Korea
and
bunch of eggs back together
the lady that didn't know but my
girlfriend knew well they were good
friends she got the acne the diagnose
with cancer
and a lot of people over there brought
money together to bring her home which
the thing that was very very cool thing
to do we had a bunch of student speakers
and they talked about race and gender
identity it was really touching just see
how they what they experienced compared
to what I would experience
when I tell a big moving experience was
for me was the first black president
that means me you know in my lifetime
I'm 61 years old and that was a there's
not a folks that passed on that didn't
get a chance to see that a black man
being president in US and that I think
was a big moment
besides King and everyone else that came
before him you know but dad really was
the deciding moment and I think it's
gonna it's going down in the history
book as the deciding moment here in the
US and I'm in there right there because
you're gonna get me started I don't want
to get stuck so i'ma leave it right
there
well my mama's in town it's her birthday
and I think about something that moved
me as my own she she survived cancer and
yeah the last time she went into surgery
I was playing a concert while she went
under the knife and then so when I
finished the show I heard that the
surgery went well
I think that that moves me
I have to say
this my mom the way they see lived her
life intended around so they said you
showed me a better way from my life or a
better path that kind of business
my life different from the jump and not
have to do a lot
a lot of establish to see with her
a lot of things that move me every
single day you mean don't you get moved
every day I do not all in all honesty um
actually something moves me is that's
what's going on right now is I'm the
best I was chosen to be a best man for a
wedding in you know it's actually like
probably the highest honor than any man
could ever get I mean this guy only has
one person that he's going to choose for
the rest of his life to live with but
he's also telling this other guy that
you're the best person that's ever been
in his life before this other person so
it's the highest honor that a man could
even get and so I'm I was moved by that
and I'm here this weekend
that make sense definitely though all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]